FIRST UNITE TO FIGHT.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
ABUSE OF OFFICE.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE CHARGES
REJECTED IN THE SENATE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD HAVE FILED
THE ARTICLE AGAINST THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE GUILTY OF ABUSING THEIR
OFFICE AND THE PUBLIC’S TRUST.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN HUNTED
AND DENAMED AND INVESTIGATED
SINCE THE DAY HE ANNOUNCED HIS
RUN FOR THE WHITE HOUSE.
DEMOCRATS, THE DEEP STATE AND
THE MEDIA ALL CONSPIRED TOGETHER
TO UNDERMINE THIS PRESIDENT BY
IMPUGNING HIS CHARACTER.
HE WAS A RUSSIAN STOOGE.
OR PUTIN WAS BLACKMAILING HILL.
HE WAS RUNNING A CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE.
IT WAS ALL FALSE, ALL OF IT.
THEY EVEN WENT AFTER HIS FAMILY.
EVEN THE FIRST LADY.
>> IN HER MOST RUGGED PAIR OF
CONSTRUCTION STILETTOS.
>> IT’S OKAY FOR DONALD TRUMP
JUNIOR AND ERIC TRUMP TO DO
BUSINESS ALL OVER WORLD.
>> JARED KUSHNER.
>> WERE THEY PAID OFF?
>> YES, YES SCRAGS YES.
--
-->> Laura: THEY IMPEACHED HIM
AND USED A FAKE WHISTLEBLOWER
WHO DOESN’T HAVE THE GUTS TO
SHOW HIS FACE.
THERE WAS NO IMPEACHABLE CRIME
BUT ADAM SCHIFF WANTED TO
INFLICT MAXIMUM PAIN ON THIS
PRESIDENT 10 MONTHS BEFORE THE
NEXT ELECTION.
NOW, THIS GETS ME.
EVEN AFTER THE PRESIDENT’S
ACQUITTAL, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
HINTING AT MORE IMPEACHMENTS.
IT’S ALL THEY KNOW HOW TO DO.
AND THEY EVEN DO THAT BADLY.
WHAT WAS THE PRESIDENT EXPECTED
TO DO AFTER ALL OF THIS?
THANK THEM.
>> HE IS GOING TO TRY TO HEAL
THE COUNTRY?
NOT A CHANCE
>> IT WAS MEAN SPIRITED AND
POISONOUS.
>> VINDICTIVE.
>> HE IS IN DEEP PSYCHOLOGICAL
DISSTRESS.
>> HE WOULD SAY IT’S TIME TO
HEAL THE NATION BUT HE CAN’T DO
THAT.
>> Laura: DO THEY WANT ROSES ON
CAPITOL HILL?
THE PEOPLE WHO THREATENED TO
HAVE HIS LAWYERS DISBARRED?
THOSE PEOPLE.
DONALD TRUMP LEFT A REALLY
COMFORTABLE LIFE TO RUN IN HOPES
OF MAKING AMERICA A RICHER AND
MORE POWERFUL COUNTRY.
HE HAS.
THE DEMOCRATS ONLY RESPONSE WAS
TO PLOT AND CONSPIRE AGAINST
HIM.
REGARDLESS OF THE FACTS OR THE
DAMAGE IT WOULD DO TO OUR
COUNTRY.
I THOUGHT ABOUT THIS TODAY
SITTING IN THAT ROOM WATCHING
HIM SPEAK, FIERY AS EVER.
THANKING PEOPLE AND ALSO CALLING
OUT ALL THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF, IT DIDN’T
HAVE TO BE THIS WAY.
THE DEMOCRATS COULD HAVE TRIED
TO UNDERSTAND TRUMP VOTERS, THE
PEOPLE THAT HILLARY CLINTON
CALLED DEPLORABLE AND MY HAVE
TRIED TO APPEAL TO THEM.
THE DEMOCRATS COULD HAVE PASSED
LEGISLATION THAT THEY AGREED
WITH INSTEAD OF SITTING ON IT
FOR A YEAR.
THEY COULD HAVE PASSED AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
INSTEAD THEY PULLED STUPID
STUNTS.
>> DEMOCRATIC LEADERS WALKED OUT
OF THE WHITE HOUSE MEETING IN
WHAT NANCY PELOSI DESCRIBED AS A
PRESIDENTIALAL MELTDOWN.
>> NANCY PELOSI ACCUSED THE
PRESIDENT OF HAVING A MELTDOWN
OVER SYRIA.
>> Laura: SEE HOW IT’S ALL IN
SYNC.
DEMOCRATS WOULD NOT CONFIRM MID
LEVEL POLITICAL NOMINEES OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND WENT
SCORCHED EARTH ON KAVANAUGH.
JUDGES ISSUED NATIONWIDE
INJUNCTIONS THAT MADE OUR
COUNTRY LESS SAFE AND TIED THE
HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TRUMP WAS RIGHT.
HE NEEDED TO BLOW OFF STEAM
TODAY.
>> ADAM SCHIFF AND NANCY PELOSI
ARE HORRIBLE PEOPLE.
IF I HAD NOT FIRED JAMES COMEY,
WE WOULD NOT HAVE FOUND THIS
STUFF.
WHEN I FIRED THAT SLEEZE BAG,
ALL HELL BROKE OUT.
IT WAS LEAKERS AND LIARS.
IT WAS ALL [BLEEP].
THESE PEOPLE HAVE GONE STONE
COLD CRAZY.
BUT I HAVE BEATEN THEM ALL MY
LIFE AND I WILL BEAT THEM AGAIN
IN I HAVE TO.
>> Laura: HE TORCHED THEM.
BUT HE’S RIGHT.
EXCUSE ME IF I DON’T GIVE A FIRE
EXTINGUISHER TO THE PEOPLE
THROWING FLAMES AT THE PRESIDENT
SINCE INAUGURATION DAY.
WHEN THEY SAY WE NEED MORE
CIVILITY WHAT THEY MEAN IS THEY
WANT TOTAL CONTROL WHERE THEY
CALL THE SHOTS.
YOU SIT DOWN AND SHUT UP AND YOU
KEEP SOPHHOVELLING TAXES TO
WASHINGTON FOR PROMISE YOU NEVER
SUPPORTED.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE A PARTY SPENT.
THEY ARE A PARTY AT WAR WITH
ITSELF.
ONE THAT EVEN IN DEFEAT HAS
GROWN CORRUPT AND DECADENT.
THEY CAN’T COUNT VOTES IN IOWA.
THEY ARE INCOMP PENT OR THE
ULTIMATE ELECTION MEDDLERS.
THE DEMOCRATS LOVED THINGS
DURING THE BUSH YEARS WHEN
REPUBLICANS MOSTLY PLAYED NICE
WHEN THE DEMOCRATIC CRITICS HIT
THEM HARD.
HOW DID THAT WORK OUT FOR THE
GOP?
THE PRESIDENT DEMONSTRATED WITH
ALL OF THIS STUFF GOING ON, ALL
OF THE ATTACKS, HE WILL WORK
WITH ANYONE AND HE HAS.
HE’S DONE THIS WITH INCREDIBLEY
SMART AND POWERFUL LEADERS WITH
A LOT OF SCARY WEAPONS.
WE WORKED WITH PRESIDENT XI OF
CHINAA.
NANCY PELOSI POINTS AND PULLS
OTHER STUNTS.
HE DOESN’T WANT TO WORK WITH
HIM.
WHAT HAS SHE ACCOMPLISHED OTHER
THAN EMBOLDENING THE RADICALS IN
HER OWN PARTY.
DO NOT BELIEVE FOR A SECOND THIS
IS ONLY BECAUSE OF THE TRUMP
ERA.
HE CAUSED IT ALL.
THEY RELENTLESS MADE FUN OF
GEORGE H.W. BUSH FOR BEING A
DUMB JOCK AND RIDICULED JOHN
MCCAIN FOR MARRYING A RICH WIFE
WHO HAS 8 HOUSES AND ACCUSED
MITT ROMNEY OF BEING MEAN TO
DOGS AND ATTACKED SARAH PALIN’S
SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD.
TODAY IS REAGAN’S BIRTHDAY.
THEY SAID HE WAS JUST A STUPID
ACTOR WHO SLEPT IN THE
AFTERNOON.
>> THESE ARE VICIOUS PEOPLE.
THEY STICK TOGETHER LIKE GLUE.
>> Laura: HE IS RIGHT.
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS THREW DOWN
THE GAUNTLET TO TRY TO BEAT US
IN OPEN COMBAT THEY WERE MET BY
AN ACTUAL FIGHTER.